the world has passed another sobering
milestone in the corona virus pandemic
the total number of global cases of the
virus has now surpassed 10 million while
the number of global deaths now exceeds
500,000 the u.s. Brazil and Britain
ranked the highest in terms of
fatalities in the US the state of
Florida has reported a record daily
increase of nearly 10,000 new cases and
four other states have also seen record
spikes infections are particularly
surging in regions that lifted lockdowns
early they've been battling the corona
virus round-the-clock but US medical
professionals are at their limits in the
state of Texas alone nearly 6,000 new
cases were confirmed in just one day
despite the rise in infections Vice
President Mike Pence went to this
Baptist Church in Dallas to speak to
hunters in the congregation even though
the total number of Cova 19 cases has
surged above two and a half million
pence remains optimistic what the
American people should know is that
because of the leadership that President
Trump has provided because of the
extraordinary innovation that we have
brought to this task we are we're in a
much better place to respond to these
outbreaks and then we were four months
ago but criticism of the government's
crisis management is growing louder in
part due to images like these before
Donald Trump's rally in Tulsa his
campaign ordered the removal of
thousands of social distancing stickers
from arena seats his rival Joe Biden
said his response to the pandemic would
have been very different I would go back
to making sure that everybody had masks
that you had PPE
lined up we have been making sure we
stockpile all the things that we need
that we don't have now the one thing we
do know these masks make a gigantic
difference as usual President Trump
didn't wear a mask while coughing over
the weekend Germany's first Airport
based coronavirus testing center is
opening in Frankfurt the company behind
the so called walkthrough Center says
it's a blueprint for the return to air
travel and a new normal for airport
let's bring in correspondent Chelsey
Delaney who is at Frankfurt Airport for
us so Chelsey this is the first Airport
Testing Center in Germany how exactly
will it work well there are a couple
different ways that people flying in or
out of the Frankfurt Airport are going
to be able to get tested there's a
there's a sort of a normal testing route
where they can come in and it will take
around six to eight hours to to get the
test so they come in they pay for it
they get the swab and then six to eight
hours later they can they can get the
test results they can do this to the day
before or if they have six to eight
hours the day of their flight they can
also do that
excuse me but then they also have a fast
track route where they can come two to
three hours before their flight and get
the the test fast-tracked and and sort
of wait around the airport for that what
the uptake for this will be is a little
unclear at this point I know a lot of
people aren't really looking forward to
spending two to three hours at the
airport more than they actually have to
but this is going to be really crucial
obviously as more flights start being
held and travel starts to resume because
a lot of countries will be requiring
flyers to to have coronavirus test
results going forward yeah certainly I
mean it will be really interesting to
see how this develops especially because
you know by and large travel has has
been pretty much halted due to the
corona virus previously we now have the
the opening of this Center is it a sign
that the travel is picking up it
definitely does come amid a pickup in in
global travel this this testing center
is particularly crucial for
international travel which this week
we're supposed to see
EU borders reopened to outside countries
so we're looking at more and more travel
from places like China from from and a
lot of that will require a greater level
of accuracy on coronavirus test but even
as travel picks up even as airlines do
start to add more flights into their
into their their lineup it is going to
take a long time for global travel to
recover most airlines are really only
operating at a fraction of their overall
capacity and they're looking at multiple
years of a recovery so something like
2023 2024 until we really see the the
global air industry recovered to its its
full power and in the meantime let's
hope that they can cut Don down on that
test time I think nobody wants to spend
three additional hours in the airport
Chelsie Delaney at the Frankfurt Airport
for us thank you and here are some other
developments in the pandemic India has
reported a new daily record of almost
20,000 nuke ovid 19 infections some
states are reimposing a full or partial
lockdown meanwhile China has rien de s--
trick to lock down near Beijing
affecting 400,000 people after an
increase in cases there and Australia's
state of Victoria is considering
reinstating social distancing
restrictions it comes after the country
reported its biggest one-day rise in new
coronavirus infections in more than two
months